Speaker 1: Let's do one more element of the
Tucker Carlson revelations from the text
messages, and then we'll move on to other text
message revelations in a private text reports.
Media Matters. Tucker Carlson called Trump
skipping the Biden inauguration destructive
on his show. He didn't mention that and
pretended that coverage of Trump skipping
the inauguration was unhinged. This is another way
in which Tucker Carlson was playing a character
where in the things he said to his audience
were completely different from the things he
said privately. Media Matters reports new
revelations from a recent court filing in
the Dominion Voting Systems defamation suit
revealed Tucker Carlson's true opinion about
Trump not going to the Biden inauguration. So
destructive. And we have the text messages here.
Tucker is told by an unknown person. Maybe you
already knew, but Gates told me Trump isn't going
to the inauguration. And Tucker says, I'd heard
that about the inauguration. Hard to believe.
So destructive. That's the right analysis.
This tells us this is worse than Tucker being
delusional. I believe this is Tucker having the
same opinion I have. And you have, which is, wow,
part of the peaceful transition of power in the
United States is that the outgoing president goes
to the inauguration of the incoming president.
The totally standard, uncontroversial view.
Tucker doesn't actually think it's a good thing
for Trump to skip the inauguration. He shares my
view. He shares what I'm sure is your view,
but that's not what he said on the air. And
if we actually go to the types of things that
Tucker did say on the air about the inauguration,
they included making fun of Jim Acosta for wearing
a mask and not mentioning ever. By the way,
it's not good that Trump is skipping this.
It's bad for the country. Here's just one
example of Tucker's coverage of that inauguration.
Speaker 2: Yeah, of losing their job. Jim Acosta,
CNN, lost his job. You may not have read that.
He's no longer going to be their chief White
House correspondent. He's still oppressed,
though, today. Jim Acosta, celebrate the
ouster of a dictator, a fascist so bad that Jim
Acosta got a book deal out of criticizing him.
Those wars are behind us now. Thank God. Jim
Acosta is celebrating. The dictator is gone.
Speaker 3: So, Anderson, this is looking
like, you know, a president or a foreign
head of state leaving Washington. And, you know,
in a way, because the president is defying these
traditions of not being a part of the inauguration
of President Joe Biden. He's almost leaving town,
like aiming at an autocrat ousted
from power, heading off into exile.
Speaker 2: It's just hilarious that
someone who is literally wearing a
black mask on camera is calling someone else
a fascist. Why are you wearing a mask? You're
not going to get COVID outside at a live shot.
Speaker 1: Okay. So Tucker's actual belief we now
know was, you know what? Jim Acosta's right. It is
a really bad thing that Trump isn't going to this
inauguration. But what he said instead was, why is
Jim Acosta wearing a mask outdoors? He is playing
a character and it's a disgusting character
and it's a profitable character. But privately,
he thought Trump should go to the inauguration and
he hates Trump passionately. These are the people.
That MAGA listens to. Will they keep
listening Now that these revelations
have come out? I don't know. Let me know.
Depends on whether they even hear about it.